what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch chapter three of the
book of boba fett make sure to go ahead
and hit that like button but before we
jump into this reaction we actually got
to say thank you to today's video
sponsor and that is surf shark vpn
that's right surf shark is one of the
best virtual private networks in the
galaxy like a mandalorian suit of armor
protecting all of your online activity
from the jawas of the internet that's a
star wars reference street cred surf
shark's top-notch encryption protects
all your searches your ip address your
personal identity information from the
dark side all while increasing your
access to content across the globe punch
maybe you're stranded on one of endor's
moons and you just gotta stream the new
season and the great gungan bake off
well surf shark can help these star wars
references are not pandering at all i
know
i know
star wars you can change your region to
anywhere in the world with the click of
a button rendering geo blocks on
streaming content and even government
restrictions a thing of the past like
the past time so use the force to hit
our link in the description box enter
our code real to save yourself 83
on your surfshark membership and enjoy
an extra three months on us 83 that's
the year return of the jedi came out
yeah return of the jedi
it's not the best one but it's a good
one
so from here on out we're gonna kick off
every episode with everything we got
wrong last week my mind jumped to
crimson dodge in the kit that was a pike
syndicate my bad and we kept referring
to the tuscan raider warrior as a guy
that's a female get ready to correct us
on everything we get wrong this time so
we could point it out next week
oh
you again a street gang of insolent
youths has been stealing my inventory
now this never happened under the other
daimyos and i am insulted on your behalf
thanks my dude i beseech you lord vet
read the streets of moses by this
scourge
and i will double my tribute to him
sweeten the deal
oh we're gonna get all cyber punk up in
this [ __ ] club espa you live in the
workers district
you all should be working there is no
work mighty damio look around you
you work for me now
then you will work for me
oh
dough nice
what do they owe you
1300 cred
take the 500 and consider it resolved if
you want to continue to do business in
my territory
if you don't like it you can move to
mars eisley
rest of you gather up your gac follow me
you want to work or not
okay
i got like power ranger bikes yeah it's
cool how like the influence of the
tuscan raiders and all those oh the
street's the most
the influence of the tuscan raiders of
influences affection towards people yeah
whoa i didn't see that creature
doing a lot with their establishing
shots this episode
oh neat nice
way to tie that back in
oh hey it's amy sedaris
the sands have belonged to the tuscan
since the ocean's dry we are happy to do
business with either party but we do not
want to be taken advantage of by paying
protection to both i'm sure you
understand
time to take out the gang clean up this
one horse town you will not hear from
the nictosan riders again we look
forward to our partnership
this man exudes patience
oh no
[Music]
oh man
oh you better destroy those nickto
riders
[Music]
this just got hella personal
yeah but not all of them died right
i'm not only testing this
jesus
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh damn that was
scary huh yeah
hell yeah
there's a good investment on these guys
oh poor guys
no
god
damn
hey
hit
[Music]
oh
get him to my back attack
takes care of the house
[ __ ]
hey man their loyalty has shown through
damn they made him just absolutely
terrifying gosh that was that was like
actually scary holy [ __ ]
enough food
go help with the patrol
how do you sneak past everyone i don't
know
it's so big
you wait for them to show their hand
these are huts
waiting will only give them another
opportunity to strike again
pardon the interruption master this is
pretty awesome man
they have brought a gift
oh god an apology
they brought tribute
no [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it is dangerous guys
here is your prisoner
i offer him back if you renounce all
claims to jabba's legacy on tatooine
jeez
he needs a place to belong have him join
yeah
hard feelings
it's just business
so godfather
quite the gift
[Music]
this one is a calf
it was bred from champions for fighting
i saved this one from myself to train
it imprints on the first human it sees
interesting but they form strong bonds
with their owners
it is said that the witches of daphomir
even rode them through the forest and
fence which is a definitely nice
oh i love what this show's doing with
the world even making the rancor a
character
there you go you got an entourage get a
little respect around town
[Music]
is this another rodriguez episode really
feels like it yeah and i mean with danny
trejo it definitely makes sense excuse
me i'll see what i'm able
did he just lock the door
last
yeah they're long gone
oh here we go yes let's do it
chase some spy kids
[Music]
oh we got renditions of both of the
droids
oh you cornered now
whoa
[Music]
wow
[Music]
that's classic
awesome
come on alita
[Music]
this is so back to the future too yeah
right yeah you definitely feel tributes
to it
i hate manure yeah
where is he
he's with the
and bikes gany
he's working with the pikes
[Music]
how many i saw a thousand at least these
are just the first wave they're going to
war
then we will be ready
yeah it's after rodriguez yep
ludwig ransom man he he did the he had
this the score in here that was uh more
sci-fi scent than before that's almost
techno quality to it definitely
capturing more of a cyberpunk quality
oh
god man this concept art is gorgeous
[Music]
really loving the way this show is
shaping up man this is this is really my
like i really really love the last
episode and then this was like okay yeah
this show's great you know because like
the first episode was this is an
introduction getting acquainted i think
uh a lot of people you know there's some
who really loved it some who were kind
of like iffy on it the second episode
won a lot more people over and then this
one just kind of put the stamp on it
like okay yeah this is great and even i
feel like compliments the first episode
more now that we have a better context
of it because
i felt like the you know the first and
second episode really there was a
flashback to rain that was
probably the stronger more emotional
pull especially the second episode
obviously and then here they really made
the present day story very gripping you
know and the stakes are really felt and
it was uh intense exciting with this
great flair of of course like spaghetti
western with some like back to the
future references in here as well like
that that last chase uh especially felt
very back to the future to me um and i
really
i really dug it man and it's of course
having like it's mafia godfather vibes
like it just feels like straight up
godfather in so many ways this this rise
of like a feeling it's like the
relationship is not obviously a
one-to-one comparison but there is a bit
of this michael corleone um
scarface sort of rise here but i would
say more michael corleone because he's
trying to he's trying to
run a criminal empire
and run this taking over a family but do
it in a way that's respectable and
admirable and kind but it's like you're
gonna have to eventually play pretty
dirty you're gonna have to go pretty
rugged you know it's but
what they've been doing thus far this
episode especially
um the expansion of things like like
right down to the rancor of you know
with the tuscan raiders who were just
perceived as like savages
and now here they've really made them
characters
and then now with the rank or you know
like
really getting a chance at the rank or
feel like an actual animal with a soul
a real being and watching boba fett's
you know childlike response to the
rancor i love it
it's it's so strong and then with such
great action you know like more along
the lines of what i've been wanting to
see from robert rodriguez you know like
that
fight with black christian was so cool
it was scary yeah like the one-on-one
part you know like the fear went down a
little bit but still like the close-ups
on him were still very imposing and like
the handheld kinetic nature of it and
the dark lighting really felt like a
creature feature brought to life in
those moments oh yeah 100 one and that
action it just hits really hard and you
feel the size and the weight and just
how formidable black chrysanthemum is
and so even though you trust that boba's
probably gonna be fine at the same time
you're like oh man he can really get
messed up right now and i i just love
like if the mandalorian kind of took all
of this and went okay here's what it's
like to really walk around in this world
and here's this really personal story of
these two characters you know this this
this guy becoming more human in a way
through his relationship with grover
here i really like that you still have
natural elements that were you know
established in the mandalorian but now
like you said with the tuscan raiders
last week and then this week with things
like the rank or you're really getting
more and more of the culture and the
anthropology and like the zoology mixed
in and i mean that's also very at home
in a western world it's like you know
you you bond to your horse or something
like that you know and yeah like i i
really loved that they took the time to
have him really get wrapped up in that
to the point where he's like yeah yeah
all this political chick in weight i
want to get my record training in right
now and bond and imprint on this
creature and and yeah like even though
it is something of a meme i guess to be
like oh you know they're just gonna keep
reaching around the greater canon for
things i really like how they are you
know fleshing out everything they choose
to bring in so that you know even if
something is a reference or is you know
going to delight certain fans of certain
corners of the star wars just
overarching franchise
they also just do it in such a way that
feels very natural and it feels like
it's for everybody because it is just
part of the world and part of the
culture and part of the life of being
here and then two you get that all
realized with the amazing production
designs
and again the really visceral action and
you know it's
coming off of rodriguez's first episode
you know of the the pilot episode you
know i think that action side did also
improve here and i love the inclusion of
like the the the cyberpunk uh uh the mod
the mod game the mod gang yeah which is
like something that's easily at home in
a world like star wars and yet feels a
little bit fresh and to see like these
bikes they'll have that are sort of
coordinated and that are so bright was
like a nice sort of
it i feel like contributes to that
homage to things like back to the future
but also in a way that's like a new
shade of something you know because
everything's so like dusty and and you
know an ill repair on tattooing well i
hope that
as we explore some of this you know i'm
remembering and didn't
please correct me
we encourage that
i'm remembering i don't know if i
remember this correctly but wasn't there
something where she like lipped up her
shirt in mandalorian season two fennec
and it showed there were some
modifications that happened to her from
the wound
so i i imagine that we'll probably see a
little bit more of the nitty-gritty
installation that you get with that
cyberpunk modifications that they do
which would be pretty cool to explore
because i like seeing that but i also
love like the body horror qualities that
sort of come with that you know and like
where they're pulling this from with
some of this they got to be pulling from
like certain droids as well oh yeah in
order to make that all happen so like
when they were saying like doing the
mods that i was like oh [ __ ] this would
be awesome yeah
so i hope in like the
you know because obviously the way the
flashbacks are going we're eventually
going to be filling in the blanks of you
know
where because boba was first teased in
mandalorian season one
uh when he saved fenix so we gotta see
like how that relationship came to be so
i'm wondering like well what are we
gonna do there with the mods are we
gonna see any of that take place
and um
yeah i'm loving that i thought fennick
was great i thought she was awesome here
yeah a lot of presents like i know that
towards the latter part of our you know
review portion of these videos in the
second episode we were like there's
something that seemed kind of off about
some of the editing or chemistry that i
couldn't quite pinpoint that i didn't
feel a mandalorian but i kind of felt in
the boba fett show and here i'm like oh
that's that was a present at all like i
think the chemistry was great i think
the way uh i think the way they utilize
her
is awesome you see like her sad her
skill set
it feels like she there is this like um
this sense of uh security when she is
around like that is her job and at the
same time you feel safer when she is
around like her capability is really
really palpable you know i i love
everything they did with her here like
this episode to me was really firing on
all cylinders and and in every way
everything from most iceland most hespa
uh tying like getting like little like
subtle easter eggs in the background the
times of the mandalorian like when they
are doing their chase too like all the
amount of droid easter eggs that you're
getting here so it was so so cool to
behold but
it does have this more like
street level grounded approach
where you would see some of these action
scenes in like just a a modern day
story you know um except you see it and
like what would it look like on in most
espo or
you know when they're going up the
stairs and stuff i'm like i like the
riff on these action scenes where you
see it realizing a star wars medium
and i think that makes it more
the connectivity tissue with the way
they visually realize everything is that
much stronger
uh and i think you know one thing too
that i've heard some people talk about i
remember this complaint kind of came up
with the first episode of boba fett
and and to me i'm always like just just
wait till this
that plays out that's usually where i
stand it's like if you question it fine
but don't label the
try not to be committed to a to an
opinion just yet
and i think this episode and especially
coming off the last one really
compliments that well is
i remember when boba first showed up in
mandalorian they were like they just
made a total 180 on this guy how is he
the most ruthless fighter and you know
all that and i i just love i love the
way they realize in the longer and then
uh and they have a book of boba fett you
know and when you see more of his like
compassionate softer side i think
they've done a really good job on
exploring that quality of him as well
and watching his relationship especially
with the tuscan raiders and how that's
formed and how this has become so
personal for him like this isn't you
know one thing i was asking myself was
like why why would they um
why would he
care to to claim this throne per se
and run this you know where's this
coming from and you're slowly watching
that why and uh
unveil itself and i think that's what
makes it such good storytelling is
because
you know these these qualities of him
where you see him all caring was
like okay i'm not used to seeing that
side of him and then you know when you
see how this the the tender moments that
form with the tuscan raiders and how he
does show a little bit more of this
wiser
approach with hiring or delegating or
you know like with the with the mod
workers instead of just being like i'm
be a ruthless badass and impose
he's like i see your problem yeah yeah i
see your potential and i see how this
guy's kind of a greedy [ __ ] you know
he needs to like make trying to find
strike the balance here you know or or
with the rank or with the uh or the
gomorian when he's injured he's like put
him in the tank heal him up you know
yeah like these little moments that show
like the the detail of his character you
know it's like making him full
three-dimensional he's someone who i've
really grown to love over the course of
these three episodes
uh it's just funny like getting
acquainted with it you know whereas um i
kind of the impression i'm kind of
getting is like mandalorian really works
as an
episode episode yeah for me i mean uh
week to week
uh where this i
structurally i kind of wonder what this
would feel like if it was a [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah you know like it feels like it
might have probably worked a little bit
better and it might be because like the
mandalorian was very
you know like a dif sort of a different
adventure and they would all eventually
tie in
uh
where
like like planet traveling and stuff and
here it's all like tattooing based and
then it's this very serial immediate
story of the rise of a of a gang war on
tatooine uh with the pikes being the
head of it which brings up questions
about uh the pike too so i know i'm like
rambling yeah yeah
but it brings other questions about the
pikes too um you know like
like the
if i if i'm not mistaken i know they
were briefly shown in in bad batch
um
in one episode in particular that that
son of someone like it's kind of a foggy
review you reacted the whole thing but i
saw it once yeah i forget who that i
remembered their masks in animation i
remember i remember the fate yeah yeah
and then obviously heavily featured in
clone wars in the final season and solo
see that's the one that i barely
remember gotta go back and legitimize
solo and that's where i was getting like
slightly confused as they're featured in
there and then i remember there was that
whole thing with kira is
with kira and and the whole uh crimson
dawn syndicates and that's why my mind
was like okay is this the crimson dawn
syndicate wait no there's the pikes in
the kit
so
is
kira gonna come into the show and in
some way i'm i'm actually not
remembering fully where we left off
there on solo because that would
technically be the last time we
is that that would be the last time we
saw them right in terms of timeline
problems solo after the clone wars stuff
yeah and that's after order 66.
well yeah i mean because han solo is not
yeah but he's a human yeah
yeah um but the darth maul was around
darth maul was around at that time yeah
and now
it's before he got killed by obama so
darth maul
is now dead based off the timeline here
yes so would would it be cure i don't
know maybe the show will unveil it yeah
they'll age her up
because it sounds like there's someone
uh
higher up above the pike so they're that
they're answering
king commander
sounds like there's someone higher up
above the pikes they're answering to
yeah um
i'm trying to try to keep up with it but
as it stands like what they're doing
here they've made the flashback stories
really engrossing
and
um you know like i like imbuing what
they why his motivation for tattooing to
be instilled with
specifically the tuscan raiders he grew
very attached to them now they're he got
imbued into their culture now a lot of
them died when this land really is
theirs
and now he's claiming it back and it
feels like some of like i imagine they
might come back in the present day
storyline
you know and help give the land some of
the land back to them well yeah he might
you know do a transfer of power
resources etc i mean not to say that the
tuscans necessarily want to leave their
you know rightful you know dune sea
homeland but at the same time i mean it
seems like they are at odds with
everybody and i loved that like you you
you were mentioning the the you know
experience of watching this week-to-week
versus potentially as a binge and one
thing that struck me about this episode
was it felt more balanced in terms of
how much time you're spending in the
present versus in the flashbacks and in
the first two episodes you know it's
like the second episode is especially
long by comparison to these two and you
spend a lot of time with the flashbacks
in those and so yeah i felt like this
one had a a more balanced uh handle on
that and i loved again that you know we
they took the time to let him mourn the
tuscans and he you know completely for
for nobody other than their own respect
and his respects being paid he gives
them this funeral wire and all that
stuff and i thought that was
really beautiful and that's the stuff
that really i think they do a lot that
speaks to his character like like the
quality of the guy that boba fett has
become true and and they've done such a
great job of yeah justifying how and why
he became this guy versus the you know
badass bounty hunter that we all you
know came to know him as and so yeah
it makes that
appearance and those changes that came
up in the mandalorian that much more
rewarding and satisfying because they
feel like they were always meant to be
there they feel like they were always
happening you know i think what they did
really well with this episode was really
placing his position right now and
making it
felt like it was established through
dialogue but this time i really felt it
of
how you got like they're talking about
the trend oceans and then like the
different oh yeah aspects people control
the area yeah here's where you are and
uh things are kind of worse with you
here and people kind of view you as a
little bit weak and you gotta earn
respect from everyone and keep this
whole powder keg from exploding like
someone comes directly to like they send
black christian directly there to
assassinate him
and i i i think they've really done a
great job at making like and now i'm
like i'm rooting for you to rise to
power yeah as before i'm like i'm kind
of watching stuff yeah and yeah and in
the present and here this one they made
the present story like really gripping
because you know one thing with the
flashbacks is as as great as it is and
more meditative as those moments are
they're um
there's a sense of safety because you
know he's gonna survive because your
flashbacks yeah and then here you know
like when like there's there's real
tension and stakes to like obviously
he'll survive because the book
uh in the present present-day storyline
but like that that's what makes those
fight scenes like with black croissants
so so um intense you know
um yeah i think what they're doing is
awesome and and i feel like a little bit
more than mandalorian you know back to
that week-to-week binge experience i
feel like more than mandalorian this
would work really well as one sitting
yeah you know just from these three
episodes alone like this feels like one
movie
you know that that is divided in that
tarantino aspect of like chapter one
chapter two chapter three like you just
skip a little bit of time uh you know
yeah and so i'm i'm really i'm really
this this one like
for the complementary effect of episode
two and three this is yeah this is great
stuff
all right guys what'd you think about it
correct us on everything we got wrong or
any questions that we have i'm bringing
up next week subscribe click that bell
hit that like button and last but not
least let's do a p
michael b
michael b you have been the
mike the beef
[Music]
michael boba michael b omni media
youtube channel covers a whole bunch of
shows and movies and such as well
wonderful reactions wonderful commentary
i've talked star wars then many times
he's a great guy and yeah he's covering
book of boba fett and if you guys are
fans of this show please do yourselves a
favor check out his reactions i'm
telling you guys it is seriously
wonderful
um i really enjoy watching your stuff
man you've been with our patreon for so
long and i know i normally correct much
sarcastic jokes and uh i could just text
you right away if i wanted to but i just
said i hear you're filming this right
now too
you're gonna get this up before us like
you always do so uh dude just keep
kicking ass this year man uh i'm i'm
expecting your channel to really blow
the hell up this year uh get shut down
uh yeah no no no get an apocalypse
yellow dollar get copyright struck all
that i'm expecting your channel to
really grow significantly man and
because you absolutely deserve it and uh
you're you're one of the best in this
reaction guy
so thank you for being you dude and kick
ass 2022 this year man absolutely
deserving 100 earned it man
[Music]